BACK TO YOU.
>> Carley: ASHLEY STROHMIER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BRING IN THE MAYOR OF ARIZONA,
MAYOR GILLES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE BORDER
CZAR COMING TO ARIZONA AND NOT
VISITING THE BORDER?
>> IT IS A GREAT STORY AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT IT IS A
LOST OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THE
BORDER AND BRING ATTENTION TO
THE SECURITY ISSUES WE'RE
FACING.
THE DRUGS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER ARE ABSOLUTELY IMPACTING
MESA, ARIZONA.
WE'VE RECOVERED 800,000 FENTANYL
TABLETS IN THE LAST TWO ANTHEM
MONTHS AND THESE ARE DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER INTO
OUR COMMUNITY.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY SECURITY
ISSUES AT THE BORDER WE WOULD
LOVE FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT TO
BRING MORE ATTENTION TO AND
BRING MORE RESOURCES TO AND AS
EVERYONE KNOWS, WE'RE FACING A
SURGE OF MIGRANTS DUE TO LACK OF
UPDATED IMMIGRATION LAWS.
WHEN TITLE 42 GOES AWAY SHORTLY,
WE'LL SEE EXTREME SURGE AT THE
BORDER OF MIGRANTS.
WE HAVE A CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
WE NEED MORE FEDERAL ATTENTION,
I AGREE WITH MAYOR ADAMS
CRITICISM OF THE LACK OF
LEADERSHIP AT THE BORDER AND
THAT APPLIES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE REFORM WE
NEED HAVE TO COME THROUGH
CONGRESS.
THERE IS BLAME TO BE SHARED ALL
OVER WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Carley: YOU MENTION MAYOR
ADAMS, HE JUST VISITED EL PASO,
TEXAS AND HE JUST WROTE A
"WASHINGTON POST" OP-ED ABOUT
THE BORDER ISSUE, WHICH IS
INTERESTING TO HAVE THE
DEMOCRATIC NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
WRITING AN OP-ED ABOUT THE
BORDER CRISIS BECAUSE HE SAYS IT
WILL COST NEW YORK CITY 2
BILLION TO DEAL WITH THE
MIGRANTS FLOODING INTO THE BIG
APPLE.
HE SAID WHAT I FOUND IN EL PASO
IS WHAT I FEARED, THE NATIONAL
CRISIS LEFT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STRUGGLING TO ADEQUATELY CARE
FOR THE MIGRANTS COMING INTO
THEIR COMMUNITY SAYS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
STATEMENT FROM MAYOR ADAMS?
>> I'M IN WASHINGTON, D.C. AT
THE U.S. CONFERENCE OF MAYOR
CONFERENCE AND I WAS WITH MAYOR
ADAMS YESTERDAY IN A CONFERENCE
ON THIS TOPIC AND I APPRECIATE
THE ENERGY HE'S BRINGING TO THE
ISSUE.
NEW YORK CITY RECEIVED 40,000
MIGRANTS OVER LAST FEW MONTHS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE AND BORDER
STATES, WE'VE BEEN LIGHTING
OURSELVES ON FIRE TRYING TO GET
ATTENTION FOR DECADES NOW, VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE MAYOR ADAMS
ENTERING THE DEBATE.
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN OVERLOOKED